for the first time Prince Harry has
revealed his deeply personal struggle
following his mother's death in an
interview with Britain's Daily Telegraph
he admitted he was close to a complete
breakdown on numerous occasions
Prince Harry was 12 years old when
Princess Diana was killed in a car crash
he said it was not until his late 20s
that he sought help to process his grief
Charlie d'Agata is at Kensington Palace
in front of the white garden which pays
tribute to the late Princess Charlie
good morning good morning these new
Memorial Gardens were just opened last
week to mark the 20th anniversary of the
death of Princess Diana she lived here
at Kensington Palace it's now home to
her two sons it's the first time Harry
has spoken so openly about the mental
struggles in coping with that loss there
was 20 years of not thinking about it
and then two years of total chaos he
said his brother Prince William finally
convinced him to get professional help
after suffering in silence the podcast
interview is conducted by Brian T Gordon
a Britain's Daily Telegraph I can safely
say that losing my mum at the age of 12
and therefore shutting down all of my
emotions for the last 20 years has had a
quite serious effect on on not only my
personal life but also my work as well
Harry just a boy at the time said it
took years to come to terms with the
loss of his mother all of a sudden all
of this grief that I'd never processed I
had to come to the forefront I was like
there's actually a lot of stuff here I
need to deal with walking behind his
mother's coffin in that scene royal
correspondent Roy anika knows Harry
pretty well having interviewed the
Prince over the years I think what he
struggled with is being able to hide his
private self in this very public sort of
spotlight and I think what he'd really
like to be able to do is just be a
little bit more natural and a bit more
at ease talking about struggles he's had
when he's in that public persona the
princes used that public persona to
carry on many of Diana's charities as
well as taking on some of his own and in
an interview with CBS this morning last
year at the launch of the Invictus games
for wounded warriors he said he hoped it
would make his mother proud this is
Mother's Day here in the United States
what do you think your mother Princess
Diana would think about what you've done
here for veterans
um I write whether for veterans or
before it was but um I think she would
I'd hope she being yeah incredibly proud
I hope she'd be sitting up there having
our own little party and looking down
thinking you know what we've achieved
because it's a massive massive team
effort what we've achieved it absolutely
brilliantly this new interview is all
about erasing the stigma surrounding
mental health issues Prince Harry Prince
William and Kate will all be cheering
runners on in Sunday's London Marathon
as part of that campaign Nora Charlie
d'Agata in London thank you you know I
remember that interview when you asked
him that question I was curious to see
how he would answer it it's so great
though Nora and that he's speaking out
he's speaking out yeah I mean so many
people especially men don't talk about
it rating on 12 is such I mean any age
to lose your mother but at 12 is it's it
sinks in very deep yeah the idea of
dealing with grief is a very personal
one but you know Sheryl Sandberg has a
new book coming out doing and I think
I've interviewed her we're going to have
that the end of this week but it is
interesting ways to deal with grief that
is not one that that leads you to this
sort of deep alone sorrow that the
principle goes with it differently there
isn't a one-size-fits-all on that and
CBS News will mark 20 years since the
death of Princess Diana in a two-hour
primetime special Gayle will host
Princess Diana her life her death the
truth at 8/7 central that's May 22nd
right here on CBS